Hattie McDaniel got one that was kind of given to her.
I sincerely hope I shall always be a credit to my race.
and to the motion picture industry.
My heart is too full to tell you just how I feel.
And I say thank you and God bless.
Yes, she won that. I mean, and that's the you know, that's another conversation...
Of, you know, people talk about, well, why are you, why are you a proponent of Gone with the Wind?
She won an Oscar! She won an Oscar and broke everybody's face.
They put her in the corner. They put baby in a corner.
Is that we're calling a Patrick Swayze call back? Thank you.
See, I'm keeping up. I'm trying to keep up with you.
And the Oscar goes to... Whoopi Goldberg.
That moment of going on stage, walking up those steps,
What was that like? What's going through your head?
Walking down an aisle to go up those steps?
I thought, OK, finally.
Finally. I wanted this. I wanted it. You know?
And people said, "Well, you know, it's a comedy it's probably not going to work."
And I thought about all the, all the people, who didn't get it.
And I thought, well...
I got it. I got this. This is mine, and that is also forever.
That's part of my moniker, Academy Award Winner. Yup!
You know, I like that.
Ever since I was a little kid, I wanted this.You don't know.
My brother sitting there he's saying "Thank God we don't have to listen anymore. You can do it now."
My mom saw me. Everybody's watching.
What's more fun, watching the Oscars at home or being there on the floor? On the stage?
Oh, well, now that I'm an old broad certainly being there is more fun.
My daughter and I went a couple of years ago.
Because I think I was presenting something, I don't know why I was there.
Oh, I do know. It was because Chris Rock was doing... He was hosting.
Which time was it? Was it when he went to the Magic Johnson Theater?
Which is maybe one of the greatest moments in Oscars history.
So I left the Kodak Theater and went down to the Magic Johnson Theater.
Did you see Million Dollar Baby? No, I sure did. And I can't lie.
And I'm not going in front of these people out here and tell you he has seen it.
And he is just like, listen, you've got to put us in some shit.
You I have to do everything, but now you've got to do it.
Because now people calling you out about it.
Then I counted at least 15 black people on that montage.
And he's gone through, I think, to where people say things about the show.
And then a few years later, go, "Oh, he was really good at it."
Is that part of the the thing that comes with it?
That people can't recognize what is you're doing.
When you're hosting the Oscars that night because of the expectations?
That people.. In that way you're talking about?
People need distance to sort of judge you as an Oscars host?
I think so. I think so. You know, and they're judging.
What you're doing without really sort of paying attention to what you're doing.
It's like the, you know, coming out as Elizabeth.
Good evening, loyal subjects. I am the African Queen.
It felt like there were 500 thousand Elizabeth Movies.
And Bette Davis did the greatest.
I mean, I'm sorry, she did the greatest Elizabeth movie ever.
Elizabeth and Essex.Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. That's what I patterned that visual on.